do you ever miss it have you ever
thought about I'm gonna have a drink
well I certainly never think that I
think once you're you know a pickle you
can't ever become a cucumber again and I
see my obsessive and compulsive
addictive qualities in other aspects of
my life they always say when you hit
rock bottom I had a situation where I
was like this is this is the moment
where you stop was was there that I did
have a moment yeah I had a moment I was
in a hotel I came out to LA to do uh I
don't even know what Fords do but I was
at the Peninsula Hotel because I was in
the grandiose phase of blowing money you
know so I'd spend lots of money so
people wouldn't think there was
something wrong you know so I was in
there and I remember being up all night
having emptied my mini bar and I just
hear I Heard a Voice say um Andrew you
do whatever you want I'm tired and it
freaked me out I like literally was
looking under the couch and under like
who just said that and that and that
just cut through to me and I made a call
that then and I went and got help